Today,
what is the leading cause of CO 2 emissions in our country?
Not our cars,
not our waste per uh the thermal insulation of our buildings The 1st cause
of CO 2 emissions in France is imports Chinese imports alone represent
more CO 2 emissions than all CO 2 emissions move.
And so,
if we want to act for the planet when we take care of a country like France,
what is the 1st thing to do Less import and more produce at home,
it is the 1st thing to do if we are rational and compose the
environmental objectives in the order,
you want to act for the planet.
The first thing to do is to turn around French industry
and stop importing Chinese products.
What I call environmental patriotism.